dust off your time machines and send
them a thousand years into the past when
you get there grab the nearest English
speaker how can you tell they're the
ones that sound like this Alec thornell
our build will do it off connect now hop
back in and turn that dial 1,000 years
into the future what will future English
be like since most of us don't have time
machines how can we predict the future
at all with fortune tellers and crystal
balls or maybe with physics which
predicts that if a certain object
travels a certain speed for a set amount
of time it will cover a certain distance
no more no less say your mom jumps in
zoomcar and tears away at 92 miles per
hour for 15 minutes when we pull out a
really really long ruler to measure how
far she's gone this equation predicts
that she'll travel precisely 23 miles
great but where's the foolproof equation
for predicting complex social things
like languages this isn't physics you
say well are there at least trends okay
here's a possibility complicated words
with a lot of moving pieces often gets
simpler over time it's not a rule but
maybe we could find more of these
patterns but it gets more complicated
because our languages look and feel will
depend on the path it takes through
future history
I mean sometimes the single language
branches out into a full family tree the
progeny might differ subtly from one
town to the next
or they might sound totally different
from each other will future English
actually turn into an entire family but
that family doesn't have to come from
proper English close your eyes and
picture what English looks like to you
did you see this if your name's
professor Cott true you sure did the
people living in this inner circle think
they speak the real English but future
English could be an underdog champ from
India or China or even inner city slang
dog remote islands jungles mountain
villages these kinds of places are
sometimes home to rare languages that
are almost like living fossils will
future English survive like a time
capsule
giving future scholars a chance to
marvel that wow this remnant sounds
almost as quaint and archaic as people
did back in the year 2014 languages can
take the middle road changing and not
changing at the same time it sounds
weird at first but all it takes is a
dash of diglossia meaning double tongues
thanks to a uniform written Chinese a
book from Beijing can be read in Hong
Kong but when locals from Beijing travel
to Hong Kong they find themselves
surrounded by a completely different
language will future English be like
this see song between a rigid cohesive
language and a patchwork of local
languages even stranger are Creoles
languages that almost come to life out
of the bones of other languages
well pissing in Papua New Guinea snags
most of its words from English but you
couldn't tell by listening to it it's
still full of foreign features seriously
they have different words for talking to
one person two people three people or a
bunch of people but a Creole is future
English is that a bit extreme
no we haven't even reached the extremes
what if in the wake of some catastrophe
only three speakers remain think of
those last speakers out there or think
of the loneliest man on earth wandering
the Amazon are these the last breaths of
once great languages
meanwhile whichever path you chose the
future of zoomcar seems pretty set it'll
just keep following this equation speed
goes up more distance covered but things
could go many ways for future English
come on imagine the sci-fi utopia Zoar
dystopias or flat-out normal Tokyo's we
might find ourselves in so perhaps what
will become a future English is not too
different than asking what will become
of future us
you